[Música]
por una amplia mayoría los chilenos
rechazaron la propuesta de la nueva
constitución y decidieron mantener la
actual que data de la dictadura de
augusto pinochet
tras el revés a la nueva constitución el
presidente de chile gabriel boric se
comprometió a dar continuidad al proceso
constituyente el mandatario confirmó que
si todas los presidentes del congreso y
a representantes de la sociedad civil
este lunes en el palacio de la moneda
para avanzar en esta línea y al menos 10
personas murieron al momento y otras 15
resultaron heridas en un apuñalamiento
múltiple en canadá la policía informó
que dos hombres atacaron a varios
transeúntes en 13 lugares diferentes de
la provincia de saskatchewan
hola bienvenidos a esta emisión
informativa de france 24 dedicada a las
principales noticias de américa soy
santiago y comenzamos en chile el país
vivió una jornada histórica por una
amplia mayoría los chilenos rechazaron
en un plebiscito adoptar la nueva
constitución y se mantiene entonces por
ahora la heredada de la dictadura de
augusto pinochet revisemos los
resultados con el 99 puntos 95 por
ciento de las mesas escrutadas ganó el
rechazo que obtuvo el 60 y 1.86 por
ciento de los votos mientras que la
opción apruebo quedó muy por detrás con
el 38 punto 14 por ciento de los
sufragios a continuación veamos el
informe de ariana villacorta
por una aplastante mayoría los chilenos
rechazaron el texto que durante un año
elaboró una convención constitucional
para reemplazar a la vigente desde la
dictadura de augusto pinochet esta
decisión de los chilenos y chilenas
exige a nuestras instituciones y actores
políticos que trabajemos con más empeño
con más diálogo con más respeto y cariño
hasta arribar a una propuesta que nos
interpreta a todos que de confianza que
nos una como país la vigente carta
magna- seguirá rigiendo aunque el
presidente de chile gabriel boric ya
anunció que convocará un nuevo proceso
constituyente y que se cumplirá con el
mandato del plebiscito de octubre de
2020 en el que casi el 80% de los
chilenos pidió un cambio constitucional
sin embargo este resultado muestra que
el apoyo de la población ha disminuido
debido a la preocupación por ciertas
propuestas ya las controversias que
involucran a los constituyentes elegidos
para redactarla algo que junto a la
crisis inflacionaria y de seguridad
supone un duro golpe para el gobierno de
bolt pues esta votación pese a que no se
trata de una elección a un cargo público
es vista como una evaluación de su
gestión
figuras políticas han afirmado que la
constitución actual debe ser enmendada
por el bien de chile algo con lo que
coinciden los ciudadanos bueno que salga
todo bien para chiles finalmente que una
chile todo este proceso el lunes los
líderes de todos los partidos políticos
se reunirán en el palacio de la moneda
para analizar los resultados del
plebiscito constitucional y este
plebiscito fue un nuevo capítulo de una
larga trama que comenzó con el estallido
social de 2019 el camino para redactar
el nuevo texto estuvo marcado por
polémicas y desafíos y los últimos meses
primó una fuerte campaña dividida entre
detractores y defensores del nuevo texto
manuel a cano con todos los detalles
comenzó en el metro de santiago la
subida del pasaje del sistema de
transporte fue la llama que prendió el
descontento social en chile- en 2019
entonces masivamente estudiantes
saltaron los controles y entraron sin
pagar a las estaciones una primera
muestra del malestar colectivo que
terminó en multitudinarias protestas el
ex presidente sebastián piñera eliminó
la medida pero esto no calmó los ánimos
al contrario expuso la inconformidad por
la desigualdad y la discriminación en
una de las mayores economías
latinoamericanas con al menos 34
fallecidos y más de 2.000 víctimas de
represión policial sólo el anuncio del
proceso para redactar una nueva
constitución logró cierta calma un
acuerdo por una nueva constitución
dentro del marco de nuestra
institucionalidad democrática así en un
primer plebiscito el 26 de octubre de
2020 los chilenos aprobaron dejar atrás
la carta magna promulgada durante la
dictadura de pinochet los ciudadanos
acudieron masivamente a las urnas a
pesar de la pandemia del 19
esta fue aprobada con 78 de apoyos
en una nueva votación llegó en mayo
cuando chile escogió los 155
constituyentes que darían forma a la
nueva carta magna dos tercios de los
elegidos fueron ciudadanos
independientes y opositores de la
izquierda y el centro izquierda
las labores comenzaron en julio de 2021
en cabeza de elisa loncón una líder
mapuche
[Música]
sí
la redacción no estuvo ajena a la
polémica
enfrentamientos entre los constituyentes
críticas de una supuesta ideologización
e incluso la renuncia de uno de sus
miembros rodrigo rojas después de fingir
padecer cáncer entorpeciera en el
trabajo
aún así el 4 de julio de este año
gabriel boliche el nuevo presidente y ex
líder estudiantil recibió el texto
de la crisis más profunda política
institucional social
los chiles
[Música]
la polarización marcó los últimos meses
hacia el plebiscito final hasta el
último minuto la campaña por el 'no' se
mantuvo fuerte las posturas se medirán
en el escrutinio de este domingo
avanzamos con más noticias de américa
latina' el presidente de perú pedro
castillo tendrá que declarar este lunes
ante la fiscalía como parte de una de
las investigaciones en su contra en
curso este proceso busca dirimir si el
castillo fue parte de una presunta
compra irregular de biodiésel por parte
de la petrolera estatal petroperú e
investigar la polémica destitución de
mariano gonzález como ministro del
interior que luego lo acusó de presunta
corrupción
al menos diez personas murieron al
momento y otras quince resultaron
heridas en un apuñalamiento múltiple en
canadá la policía informó que dos
hombres atacaron a varios transeúntes en
13 lugares diferentes de la provincia de
saskatchewan los sospechosos se fugaron
y las autoridades informaron que las
víctimas fueron aparentemente elegidas
al azar
en este momento de nuestra investigación
hemos localizado a 10 personas
fallecidas en tres lugares de la
comunidad de james phillips tri nations
wheldon saskatchewan varias víctimas
adicionales han resultado heridos 15 de
cuales en este momento han sido
trasladadas a varios hospitales
actualmente estamos buscando activamente
a los dos sospechosos ayudando a las
víctimas e investigando las numerosas
escenas de crimen estamos dedicando un
máximo de recursos a esta investigación
y en costa rica las solicitudes de asilo
rebasan la capacidad de la oficina que
los tramita los migrantes de la vecina
nicaragua huyen en busca de un mejor
futuro un fenómeno que supera la cifra
de los años 80 cuando las guerras
civiles obligaron a cientos a huir de
sus hogares el informe de andrés
granadillo un sistema colapsado vendido
la cantidad de solicitudes de asilo de
nicaragüenses en costa rica por lo que
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
ayuda con personal el sistema de refugio
de costa rica ha tenido dificultades
para hacer frente a ese incremento tan
importante de solicitudes de refugio que
ha habido desde 2018 el acnur ha apoyado
al gobierno de costa rica mediante la
contratación de 50 personas en la unidad
de refugio que ayudan a procesar estos
casos y hacer frente al rezago ahora de
tantos años este por la acumulación de
casos las peticiones suman unas 200.000
una cifra que representa el 4 por ciento
de la población costarricense y son más
de los que hubo en la década de los 80
durante el éxodo ocasionado por las
civiles en la región unas 50.000
personas están esperando cita para hacer
una solicitud formal costa rica con 5
millones de habitantes fue el segundo
país después de eeuu en recibir el mayor
número de aplicaciones de asilo la cifra
se ha incrementado desde 2021 cuando el
presidente nicaragüense daniel ortega
arremetió contra la oposición y
encarceló parte de ella costa rica sigue
siendo la primera opción para los
nicaragüenses que emigran con mayor
motivo de juego por beneficio de trabajo
trabajito que uno puede lograr a tener
allá
es complicado para el mantenimiento de
la familia
y gracias a dios aquí en costa rica nos
dan el apoyo de
trabajar y ayudar un poco más a la
familia
muchos de ellos al ver la demora en sus
peticiones ponen sus ojos hacia eeuu y
méxico donde esperan lejos de casa tener
un futuro
hasta aquí esta emisión informativa
recuerden que pueden hacer estas
noticias y conocer muchas más en france
vídeo cuatro.com sigan junto a nosotros
[Música]